when students go to university to study
mathematics the undergraduate fantasy
that we teach is that we have this
Bedrock of axim and everything is built
solely on these axim through deductive
argument and that we have a tearing
edifice of brilliant mathematics all of
which is solidly established in an
incontrovertible way that's a beautiful
kind of conception the problem is that's
not true it's not even close to true
it's almost impossible to live up to
that fantasy some of the top
mathematicians in the world have been
looking at this as a philosophy question
I've been actually working with
AI if you start always inputting your
ideas your proofs into a machine at what
point does the machine do a better job
of helping Guess The Next Step obviously
this is something very hot right now
it's moving fast and the question
becomes well what is it we want from
proofs what have we historically needed
from proofs what is it we believe when
something things proved and how does AI
change that these are massive questions
that that are popping out of woodwork
right
now I'm Andrew Granville I work in
analytic number Theory when I was young
I worked on firas Last Theorem before it
was proved today I work in ideas of L
functions and multiplicative functions
but I'm interested in all different
aspects including computational and
algorithmic
questions I've long been interested in
popular writing and Mathematics my
sister is a writer we've been thinking
it would be fun to do a graphic novel in
mathematics so we worked together to
develop it and eventually wrote it in
the graphic novel I felt like there was
room for us to develop
philosophy a philosopher of mathematics
Michael Hallet read it and he was very
interested in the way we portrayed
mathematics being
done you cannot prove them because you
cannot go back to anything more more
primitive than those propositions
themselves they are not in need of
justification talking to Michael I
realized there is this debate of what it
is we mean when we say we've got
something
proved so Aristotle said that to prove
something is true to establish it's true
your argument should rest on what he
called Primitives things you already
knew to be true and eventually there's
got to be some atoms there the So-Cal
axium that you rest all your arguments
on the basic things you cannot Define so
like point line plane if you're talking
about geometry you can't define those
what you do instead is lay down some
axioms about them the the phrase that
comes to my mind is these truths are
self-evident um which you know is
interesting at many levels when you
compare it to mathematics I mean there's
a certain arrogance about it the way
it's traditionally been done is that we
publish papers and there papers are put
in journals or books and
those books are put in libraries and
then when we wanted to verify a truth we
go to the library and we' check out the
book and we'd see if it was exactly as
we wanted it it would help us gain new
understanding or we'd have to revise
what was in those books today the
artificial intelligence that is used for
proof they're doing something similar
except they're going to store that
information within the
program so programs like lean have a
library of things already proven based
on axioms and then with suitable work
and it's complicated a mathematician can
input their proof into lean and verify
all the steps logical at least according
to lean so what does lean do I think I
have a proof of a theorem and I want a
formal proof I've written something that
I'm a bit iffy about I don't want to get
into all of the details of the ins and
outs of you know as you sort of go back
through the tree of knowledge
everything's really going to work so the
idea is to input that into lean it acts
like an obnoxious colleague who just
won't let go if a don't understand a
will not stop pestering you annoying
questions but sometimes those colleagues
actually help you because by explaining
it to them you realize oh yeah oh and
it's simpler than I thought this is
particularly famous example by Peter
schulzer he had a very very difficult
proof but he wasn't 100% sure of he
would try and say well this is true and
you should know this lean and lean would
say I don't know this at all you're
going to have to explain this better the
bits where he had been uncomfortable
with what he'd written it was where it
asked the most questions so he felt okay
that was verification it was sensibly
asking the right questions so it's an
exciting time the question is will
machines change
mathematics how do you get computers to
lead you in a proof not just follow you
or make suggestions but prove things
itself this is something in its INF y a
lot of the work on computer generated
proofs up to now has not done much of
consequence I'm very interested within
itself but not in the bigger picture but
there are some very interesting exciting
new ideas which one has some optimism
that we may see the start of generating
interesting new proofs and so this
starts to become a little frightening I
mean we value our profession we value
our work by the profundity of proofs but
if we can rely on a machine get all the
details right most of the details right
then who are we what is our training
what is it that we
value so when we don't need to think
about proof then we're not going to be
trained in thinking about proof so who
are we going to become we're going to
become more like physicist probably and
say any old nonsense and just hope the
computer verifies it I think it's very
hard to predict what even will be the
point of doing mathematics in 30 40
years
time the idea of computer Genera proofs
these present new
possibilities over time we see of course
more and more things that computers are
able to do um and it's very unclear what
limits there
[Music]
are